starting with the figure shown perform
the following transformations reflection
over the line y equals X minus 2
translation by 3/3 in the X direction so
we're going to increase we r going to
shift to the right by 3 and then shift
down by 9 is a transformed figure
congruent to the original figure and
actually we could answer this question
before we even do the transformation
because this transformation only
involves reflections and translations as
long as we're only reflecting
translating and rotating we're going to
get to a congruent figure the thing that
will make it not necessarily congruent
is when we dilate it so dilating it is
going to actually scale it up or down
the figure will still be similar but it
won't necessarily be congruent anymore
so I can already say yes the figures are
congruent but let's actually perform the
translation that they or the the
transformation that they want us to so
reflection over the Y of the line y
equals x minus 2 and so let's click on
translate and this isn't popping up this
isn't good allowing to just do it by
hand or you it with our mouse they want
us to today want us to they want us to
think about how much actually we don't
wanna translate first we want to reflect
first so once again they don't the
reflection line tool doesn't show up
instead for this exercise they want us
to specify two points of on the line
that we want to reflect around so we
essentially just have two because two
points define line so what are two
points that are on the line y equals x
minus 2 well when X is equal to 0 Y is
negative 2 so when X is equal to 0 Y is
negative 2 and then another point on it
that might jump out at you and X is 2 y
is 0 when X is 2 y is 0 so we just need
any two different points on that line
and then notice y equals x minus 2 is a
line that looks like this I'm just going
to kind of trace it I don't have my
drawing tool out right now so it's a
line that looks something like something
like that actually let me let me do it
just because I think it'll be
interesting to look at so let me copy
and paste let me copy and paste this
right over here and then let me put it
on to onto my actual
scratchpad so that's from a previous
problem so let me clear all of this
business out see if I can have some
there you go so let me paste it right
over here and notice we just reflect it
around the line y equals x minus 2 y
equals X minus 2 let's see it has its
y-intercept right over there has a slope
of 1 so this is the line that we just
reflect it around so let me and it looks
pretty clear that that is what happened
so just like just like that I know my
line isn't as straight as it could be
but you get the general idea that is the
line y is equal to X minus 2 notice each
of these points each of these points you
take you drop a perpendicular from that
point whatever distance that is go the
same distance on the other side and we
have reflected over drop a perpendicular
same distance on the other side drop a
perpendicular same distance on the other
side and so that is our reflection about
the line y equals x minus 2 but we are
not done yet we now have to perform the
translation by 3 negative 9 so let's so
it's essentially going to so we're going
to translate so when we do it by 3 it's
going to shift this to the right by 3
and then negative 9 which is going to
shift it down by 9 and we see that it
did and like and we already said these
are definitely congruent we did we
haven't scaled this up or down we've
just translated it rotated it actually
we didn't even rotate it we've just
translated it and reflected or reflected
it and translated it but let's check our
answer just to feel good about ourselves
and we got it right